In 2025, AI copywriting tools hit a 78%
adoption rate across the industry.
Copywriting was named the third most at
risk profession because of AI and the
creator economy exploded past a $250
billion value while traditional
copywriters were fighting for scraps.
What the is going to happen in 2026?
That's exactly what we're going to be
talking about in this video today. So,
stick around. By the way, my name is
Alan Dragu and I've sold over $2 million
with my copywriting and I have over
10,000 followers and subscribers across
my email and social who study my
copywriting. This is what I do all day
long. Okay, let's get the obvious thing
out of the way. AI is going to play a
massive part in the copywriting world in
2026. It's going to get better. It's
going to get smarter. More people will
use it. The market will become more
saturated. All that those are not trends
and predictions. At least that's not
what I'm going to focus on in this
video. I'm going to focus on what
happens because of that, the things you
may not be paying attention to, the
layer below the layer. And I'm going to
do that by breaking down five
predictions based on trends that I'm
seeing. Starting with number one, warm
traffic will dominate cold traffic copy.
In 2025, 83.3%
of content marketers said that they used
AI to help them create their marketing
campaigns. It is estimated that about
90% of content marketers will use AI to
create content and ads and things like
that. While that stat is going up, what
is going down is cold traffic conversion
for direct to purchase. Okay? What I'm
talking about here is you're running
meta ads, you're running Tik Tok ads,
you're running Twitter ads, whatever it
is, you are running ads for a directto
purchase campaign. See ad, buy thing,
that's a direct to purchase campaign.
And those conversion rates are
statistically going down. People are
more skeptical of products, companies,
the marketing itself. And have no doubt
that AI is playing a massive role into
the conversion rate dropping. Like a
typical conversion rate for a directed
purchase could be anywhere between 1.5%
to 2.5% based on the industry. It is now
going below that 1.5% where the new
industry average is probably going to be
1 to 2% and then it's going to be 0.5 to
1.5% and it's going to continue to drop
until somebody breaks the trend. The
thing that is working is things like
bribes and lead magnets and free stuff
in exchange for emails that then
captures the information of somebody,
their phone number, their email, their
whatever, and they get warmed up with
welcome sequences and emails and text
messages and things like that. Taking
cold traffic, warming them up, and then
making the sale. The direct to purchase
sale is not working nearly as well as it
did, and AI has a big part to play with
that. Either way, cold traffic is
continuing to get dominated by people
who are sending emails and building
relationships via copywriting as opposed
to just trying to sell them in one fell
swoop. That's going to continue to die.
Prediction number two, blogs will and
are making a comeback. Here's what's
happening in the blog world. So LLMs,
right, large language learning models,
AI, all of these things are scraping
websites like Reddit and high quality
websites with lots of blog content to
understand the information that people
are prompting so it can condense it,
hand it to you. And so while the
traditional like Google search to SEO to
blog, that format is dying, LLMs are
taking the same exact route but giving
it to you in a more condensed chat form
and they are learning it from blog
models which is exactly why I completely
redesigned my website to include all my
emails and articles and social content
and all those things condensed into a
high quality website so that when people
are prompting things that I have the
answer to, it is scraping my site and
giving those answers. Yes. Will it rip
me? For sure it will rip me. But it will
also recommend my ideas. It'll recommend
my products, my articles, and all kinds
of things like that to people who are
searching for those things, which is
going to play a bigger and bigger role
and people finding about you, your
business, your brand, and all the things
that you do. Blogs are going to be a
thing. And since blogs are coming back
to life, how about prediction number
three? Mega Info products are dead.
People are not going to buy $500 plus
courses with 40 plus hours of content
and interviews and things like that.
That trend has been dying for four or
five years and I will declare them
officially dead in 2026. What is
happening instead is people are going to
AI to get very practical by bite-sized
pieces of information on their very
specific problem right now. And so that
should dictate how you if you are a
course creator or you create info
products and that is your business
model, you should be creating smaller
bite-size info products at bite-size
prices. So instead of creating one mega
course, find one tiny problem that you
solve, package it very specifically and
sell it for an affordable price. And
preferably make it really practical,
something that they can use instantly,
not 30, 100, 50 pages that they have to
read, but something simple, a template,
a copy and paste, a prompt, something
easy. Then once you get buyers that buy
those things, upgrade them to other more
robust advanced products. Which leads to
prediction number four. Creator work
will outpace client work. Here's the
thing that we're learning. A lot of
people are thinking about AI and creator
work. As copywriters are now using AI to
write copy for their clients, you guys
are thinking about it backwards. This is
not the way that it's going to be done
and it's not the way you could do it. It
is now more accessible than ever for you
to be a solo business. One of the
reasons copywriters have been
freelancing for clients for a long time
is because they don't have to carry the
burdens that it comes with running a
business. The accounting, the taxes, the
hiring people, all that extra minutiae
crap. You're like, I just want to write
copy, so I'm just going to find a client
and write the copy. that is becoming
significantly more simple and accessible
than ever because you can use AI tools
to do your accounting, to do your
systems, to do your finances, to do your
taxes, to do your automations and all
the crap like that, which makes it so
much easier for you to be a oneperson
business. And that business can work for
yourself, sell your own products, write
your own content online, paid
newsletters, paid communities. The
internet is your playing field. And it's
never been easier to be a oneperson
business. So, I have a feeling that more
people will take advantage of not having
to work for clients and build their own
internet business. I'm betting so big on
this prediction that I actually opened
up a school community called Copy
Creator, where I am teaching copywriters
how to do this, how to turn their skill
set into a leverage-based email business
that has nothing to do with clients, but
that they can scale their own content.
If you're interested in what that looks
like, you can click the link in the
description below. But that is my
prediction for client work versus
creator work. And prediction number
five, boring copy will demolish hyper
copy. The saturation of people using AI
for copy. What it is is AI is now
trained on copywriting, traditional
copywriting, which is pretty hyper,
pretty flamboyant, pretty out there,
pretty big claim. I'm going to 10x your
business, 5x your leads. I'm going to
triple your business overnight. This is
the type of stuff that current AI and
LLM models are trained on. And that's
what's going to saturate the market.
They're going to oversell and hard sell.
And as cringey as it already is, I think
it's about to get more cringe. So what
do you do when a market is saturated
with one style of writing? You go the
opposite. So now you start saying a lot
simpler, more boring claims that sound
more realistic and believable. Even
going as far as what Ben Settle calls
shaking the skeleton, meaning you start
showing the flaws of your products, your
ideas right in front of people. Hey,
it's going to help you do this, but it's
not really good at doing this and that.
And people are going to start to connect
it to and actually start to believe what
you are saying. I think it's going to
get worse before it gets better. But you
can hop on the train of writing much
simpler, boring copy in your emails,
your ads, your landing pages, and that
is going to be significantly more
trustworthy copy than what you're going
to see in 2026. That's it. That's all I
got for you. Those are my five
predictions. To recap us, warm copy is
absolutely going to dominate cold
traffic copy. Blogs are going to make a
huge comeback. Mega info products are
dead. Creator work will outpace client
work. And boring copy will beat hyper
copy. If you enjoyed this video, if you
like those stakes, I'd love to hear what
predictions you have for 2026. We'll
look back at the end of the year and see
which ones were right, which ones are
wrong. Leave a comment down below what
your predictions are. But before you
leave, please do me a favor. Take a
second if this video was helpful for
you. Like the video and subscribe to the
channel. It tells me that you want more
content like this. And lastly, I've got
a link down below where I've got a bunch
of cool free stuff on my website for
you. I've got Copywriting Catalyst,
which is a free copywriting guide. I've
got a hundred super sticky headline
templates that you can grab absolutely
free. My book, Meaningful Marketing. I
got a bunch of copywriting goodies out
there for free that you can grab. Just
click the link below, grab whatever you
want. Hope this is helpful and I'll
catch you on the next one.